what's the worst pain you've ever
experienced
a broken bone
touching something hot
maybe stepping on a sharp toy
well in this what-if experiment you'll
learn what real pain feels like
what would be the most painful
experience you could have
what different types of pain would you
feel
and
why could pain
be good for you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you experienced the most
painful things
pain is your body's way of telling you
that something's wrong
it's the result of lightening fast
messages sent between your nerves and
your brain
pain comes in many shapes and sizes and
everybody experiences it differently
it can feel like throbbing
stabbing or just steady aching
and it can leave you feeling sick to
your stomach angry or
even depressed
so brace yourself you're about to enter
a world of extreme pain
[Applause]
childbirth the pain you feel in
childbirth is from contractions of the
uterus and pressure on the cervix
once your water breaks and you're in
full labor
this pain only gets worse
you'd experience cramping under your
belly or pain radiating all around
it could be so bad that you'd have
tunnel vision and tune out everything
around you
yeah delivering your child could feel as
if somebody was pulling your internal
organs out
kidney stones
kidney stones are a hard mineral
material made from chemicals in your
urine
when these stones get stuck in your
ureter you'd experience severe cramping
and sharp pain on either side of your
lower back
it would start out of nowhere and then
it would come in waves
but it would feel like being stabbed in
the back and then having that knife
twisted
toothache
toothaches are often caused by nerve
irritations at the root of a tooth
they can be sharp and sudden or a
constant throbbing
and sorry to say they often get worse at
night so if you thought falling asleep
would give you some relief
well you'd be wrong
cluster headache
cluster headaches are considered one of
the most painful types of headaches
they come from a nerve pathway in your
brain responsible for the sensation of
heat and pain in your face
without warning you'd feel intense pain
in or around one eye and this burning or
piercing feeling could last anywhere
from 15 minutes to 3 hours
it would pretty much feel like your head
is about to split wide open
broken femur
the femur is the bone in your thigh that
stretches from your hip to your knee
if you broke your femur you'd feel
immediate and severe pain
it would take a lot of force to break
this bone so you'd feel it in the hip
back and buttocks too
the feeling would be a mix of deep
radiating pain and
total numbness
almost like freezing your leg on the
outside while dousing it in flames on
the inside
burns
second degree burns not only affect the
top layer of skin but the second layer
too
superficial burns of the second layer of
skin are initially the most painful
when the first layer burns off it leaves
nerve endings exposed and that means
that even a gentle breeze could cause
agony
appendicitis
[Music]
appendicitis is an inflammation of your
appendix
you'd feel a sudden pain in your lower
right abdomen that would start to move
any physical movement could make the
pain more severe so be careful when you
cough or
could feel a sensation similar to
multiple knives carving up your insides
trigeminal neuralgia
there's no way to prepare for it but
when a blood vein presses against the
trigeminal nerve you could be close to
one of the most painful feelings
possible
yeah it would be more severe than a
heart attack
you'd feel a sudden jolt almost like
getting zapped with tons of electricity
at first it would only be for a few
seconds but it could start to last
longer
it would be so intense that you'd be
unable to eat or drink anything
tetanus
you could become infected with tetanus
after a puncture injury like stepping on
a nail
it's caused by a bacteria that produces
a poison resulting in sudden involuntary
muscle contractions
you'd arch your neck and back your legs
would stiffen like rocks and you'd
clench your fists tightly for several
minutes at a time
ah
oh
man
i need to check if i'm up for another
tennis shot
stone fish sting
hey this list wouldn't be complete
without some animal kingdom
representation
the 13 spines on the back of the
stonefish could inflict a ton of pain on
you
these spines are full of venom
this venom would cause intense swelling
around the sting and that swelling and
pain would quickly spread to the whole
limb
you'd be so preoccupied with the feeling
of a gigantic sledgehammer slamming down
on the affected body part that
you wouldn't even be able to put your
pain into words
okay that was intense
after all this pain
you wouldn't be crazy to wish you never
experienced pain at all
but
that's a story
for another
what if